shinji eine der großen touristen
hotspots albaniens
hochsaison in der hafenstadt an der
nördlichen adria küste die hauptstadt
tirana liegt eine autostunde entfernt
vor allem albaner aus dem benachbarten
kosovo machen hier urlaub
das hotel raphael ist eine der großen
bettenburgen hier
650 zimmer hatte es zwei große pools
noch immer herrscht ausgelassener
badebetrieb
neben den urlaubern in feierlaune
geflüchtete aus afghanistan
800 leben noch hier was für sie nur ein
zwischenstopp sein sollte auf dem weg in
die usa oder kanada ist zu einem fast
einjährigen aufenthalt geworden in
quälendem wachte modus
in diesem hotel restaurant essen nur
geflüchtete angeles tragen die kosten
für drei mahlzeiten und unterkunft 25
dollar pro tag und kopf egal welchen
alters
bei einer rundumversorgung für die
geflüchteten ein unwirkliches leben im
transit am hotel eine krankenstation die
speziell für die geflüchteten
eingerichtet wurde die afghanische arzt
den frohsinn ahmadi verdient sich hier
ein kleines taschengeld dazu sie weiß um
die psychischen probleme um das warten
dass sie und ihre landsleute langsam
mürbe macht das gefühl von der welt
vergessen worden zu sein viele der
patienten nehmen antidepressiva
das große problem für alle afghanischen
flüchtlinge die hier in albanien leben
ist dass es keine sicherheit gibt ob und
wann wir albanien verlassen können
noch ein monat noch eine woche noch fünf
jahre
das ist hier die große frage und
bereitet uns große schwierigkeiten wenn
sie fragen wie lange es noch dauern wird
heißt es immer wir wissen es nicht ihr
müsst warten
ab und so sind sie am strand die
anwältin muslime datei und ihre kinder
auch sie kamen wie so viele hier im
vergangenen oktober nach albanien erst
kurz vor abflug hatten sie erfahren dass
die reise über katar nach tirana gehen
wird
[Musik]
so richtig freuen kann sich muslime
nicht vor allem auch weil sie der
gedanke an ihre mutter und ihre
geschwister nicht loslässt die sie in
afghanistan zurücklassen musste
die witwe ist und meine zwei jüngeren
geschwister die wir alle finanziell
unterstützt haben gehen jetzt in
afghanistan durch schwere zeiten
und wie geht es dir dabei
entschuldigung entschuldigung
leben immer noch versteckt in einem
keller irgendwo in kabul und haben große
finanzielle sorgen
war ja aber können hier nicht arbeiten
um ihr geld zu schicken wir sprechen
kein albanisch und sind ja auch nur
temporär hier auf einem zwischenstopp
die reise soll ja weitergehen
gott möge es nicht zulassen meinem
bruder oder einer schwester irgend etwas
zustoßen sollte werde ich in meinem
leben nicht mehr glücklich würde mich
vielleicht sogar umbringen denn sie sind
wegen mir in gefahr
muslima ist anwältin leitete das
frauenbüro in einer nördlichen provinz
in afghanistan ihr engagement galt vor
allem der prävention von gewalt gegen
frauen
sie etablierte frauenhäuser klette
frauen über ihre rechte auf vertrat sie
vor gericht kaum an der macht schickten
die taliban ihr drohen nachrichten
durchsuchten unzerstörten ihr büro in
einem keller in kabul hat muslime und
ihre familie aus bis eine ngo sie auf
eine der reitenden listen setzte
treffen mit freundinnen im hotelzimmer
jeder hat hier ihre ganz eigene
geschichte wie die fußballerin fach
rondell jusufi die ihr baby auf der
flucht in doha bekam
es gibt viele kinder hier ein drittel
der geflüchteten sind unter 15 eine
geschlossene gesellschaft eine
parallelwelt allemal
denn am abend im hotel raffaello wird
wie immer ausgelassen gefeiert die lang
ersehnten ferien neigen sich dem ende zu
unter den zahlreichen nachtschwärmer so
gut wie keine afghanischen flüchtlinge
dem journalistenschar ab nur ist nicht
zum feiern zumute seit fast elf monaten
stecken sie hier fest das warten kaum
mehr auszuhalten
in seinem youtube kanal kabul görner
erzählt er von der albanischen diaspora
von der agonie von den protesten weil es
einfach nicht weiter geht
wir wurden vergessen wir wollen die
evakuierung wir wollen um unsere zukunft
wissen
wenn du in einem hotel liebst immer auf
abruf nicht genau weißt wohin die reise
geht
ist das schwer zu ertragen viele der
menschen hier haben depressionen
jeden tag wird das datum der evakuierung
verschoben werden es die vereinigten
staaten seien vielleicht für das kanada
keiner weiß ist das ist schwer
auszuhalten
[Musik]
für muslime hat ihren mann und ihre
kinder hat das warten vielleicht bald
ein ende
es soll nach kanada gehen sobald die
flügel nicht mehr ganz so stark mit
touristen ausgelastet sind
das hat man ihnen jedenfalls versprochen
muslime hofft auch dass sie dann ihre
mutter und ihre geschwister zu sich
holen kann die nach wie vor in großer
gefahr sind